- I am here with lifestyle expert
and green living guru, Danny Seo.
(audience applauding)
Who, by the way, I'm starting to think
maybe we were separated at birth.
Because I believe I'm so interested
in so many of the things you discuss,
and live, and are true in your life.
So what are we gonna be doing here?
- What we're doing is,
we're going to up-cycle a children's book
into this beautiful storybook bird house.
- [Drew] I absolutely love it.
- [Danny] It looks complicated,
it's So not complicated.
- Okay, show me how it's done, Danny.
- So first step, this is
like $2 at a craft store.
It's just a regular
unfinished, wooden bird house.
- By the way, which bird
is fitting in there?
Why are bird house holes so small?
Does the bird become liquid
when it goes through these?
Because I don't get it.
And it's every bird house.
The openings are literally
the size of a quarter.
- [Danny] I think they can fit.
- How?
- I think they're small.
You know, we're not talking
about pigeons or seagulls.
- But it's like every bird
house has really small holes.
- You know...
I will, I will look into that.
(everyone laughing)
- I need to know because
every time I stare at it,
it gives me anxiety.
Like, do they have to force
themselves through there?
Okay, thank you, Danny.
Help me 'cause it does give me anxiety.
- We're gonna do something
called decoupaging.
What you do is you take a book,
I've already taken all
the pages out of the book.
And you just, sloppily,
put on as much glue
as possible, all over it.
- And is this the special decoupage glue?
- It is.
So what you do, is you
take the page you want,
just plop it through, go
right through the hole.
Use your fingers to actually
get the paper on, like this.
And then what you do,
is that the more glue you get on,
the more it's gonna seal it.
And the more it's going
to really get the pages
stuck on here,
- [Drew] Okay. So then
we do the glue on top?
- On top too, 'cause you
really want to saturate it.
'Cause it really, then it sticks.
And when it dries, it seals it too.
So while it looks really
messy and sloppy right now,
this glue dries to a perfect
finish every single time.
- Really?
- And then the fun part
is, if you got the kids,
'cause you got that little you know,
that hole at the top right here?
It's like, how do you do that?
You just boop, stick your
finger right through it.
And then take that extra paper...
- I don't think I can get
my finger, oh, there we go.
- Look at that. You're
already like two seconds.
We're already getting this
bird house, like on its way.
And then you just go around and around
and keep adding more glue.
And then you layer the paper on top.
- Okay.
- If you don't like, let's
say you don't want to do this
because it's already saturated.
You can just tear it.
You see how it just naturally tearing
into the shape of the bird house?
And you go around and around like this
until you're actually
finished with the birdhouse.
What you could do, if you
only have one bird house,
and you're doing let's say
a kid's party or something,
you could also cut out all the characters.
- Oh, I like that.
- And start layering and
create a little story book
on here too.
Or if you don't want to cover
the whole thing in the pages,
you could paint it first
and then actually create little stories
of your own with the characters.
- Oh, that's cute. Like
a story book, bird house.
- [Danny] That's exactly it.
- [Drew] Oh, I love that.
- And what I love is that
the cost of something
like this is a few dollars.
For this effect, you
don't have to do the roof,
because your actual book
jacket becomes the roof.
- [Drew] Oh.
- [Danny] You see?
And then you really just
go around and around
and keep adding things
like this until you have...
(audience applauding)
- A beautiful storybook bird house.
Now Danny, here's the thing,
mine's never going to look like yours.
Mine's gonna look like
this, which is, you know...
- I think there's a
lot of beauty in truth.
The truth is you can't make it.
(everyone laughing)
- It's so true. It's so true.
- [Danny] Just so you know,
this project does not work if
you use pages of my magazine.
It's very weird.
- Really?
Yeah. It just, it just
rejects it completely.
- It's like a glossy paper
stock that won't be decoupaged?
- No, I just don't want people
tearing apart my magazine.
(everyone laughing)
- [Drew] Oh, okay.
Well, I shan't.
I shan't maim your magazine.
And I just thank you so much, Danny.
And be sure to pick up your copy
of "Naturally Danny
Seo" on newsstands now.
It's quarterly, right?
- [Danny] Quarterly, yep.
- Thank you, Danny.
- [Danny] Thank you, Drew.
- Thank you, guys. This was so fun.
(audience applauding)